merci mesdames et messieurs les
journalistes
et nous sommes aujourd'hui réunis pour
vous présenter les principales
conclusions et recommandations du
rapport de la mission d'information
flash sur les zones à faible émission
mobilité les ZFM avant toute chose je
tiens à saluer et à remercier
mon collègue le rapporteur Philippe
Tabaro d'avoir conduit ce travail sur un
sujet
tout le monde en conviendra sujet est
très épineux et dans un délai aussi bref
je rappelle que la mission a été
constituée au début du mois de mars
dernier
comme vous le savez les zf1 ont été
créés par la loi d'orientation des
mobilités la loi de l'homme
texte que la Commission de l'aménagement
du territoire que j'ai l'honneur de
président
avait examiné début 2019
en réponse aux problématiques de
dépassement récurrent des normes de
qualité de l'air
normes récurrente de dépassement des
qualités des normes de la r dans les
certaines agglomérations le régime c'est
vu considérablement renforcé par la loi
climat et résilience texte que notre
commission avait examiné dès l'été 2021
et donc il est Tabaro était déjà
également le rapporteur sur le volet se
déplacer ce rapport de la mission flash
ZFE dont Philippe Tabarro va dans
quelques instants vous présenter les
grands actes constituent cela en un
rapport d'application de la loi climat
résilience il s'agit d'un jalon précieux
qui près de deux ans après l'adoption de
la loi nous permet de faire un point
d'étape sur l'application de la loi et
sur les évolutions envisagées
je ne serai pas plus long je laisserai
la parole à notre rapporteur à Philippe
Tabaro car vous dire mais vous
l'expliquera mieux que moi que nous
avons présenté ce dossier ce matin en
commission et que nous avons et que ce
rapport de Philippe Tabaro a reçu
un plébiscite sur effectivement alors il
y a eu beaucoup d'échanges très
intéressant d'ailleurs beaucoup
d'échanges sur ce sur ce dossier mais
qui a reçu quasiment un vote à
l'unanimité et donc je ne serai pas plus
long et sans tarder la parole au
rapporteur qui va nous exposer les
principaux constats et recommandations
issus de son travail merci à vous
[Applaudissements]
je voudrais particulièrement vous
remercier pour votre pour votre présence
alors je sais que il y a une ministre
qui était particulièrement attendu
aujourd'hui dans la maison pour une
audition j'ai vu beaucoup de vos
confrères
[Musique]
se balader dans les couloirs ce matin
pour pour avoir quelques images de
l'audition de la ministre et vous avez
préféré vous venir vers le sujet des
mobilités j'en suis ravi j'en suis
particulièrement flatté ainsi que je
l'imagine le Président longeaud je
voudrais remercier très sincèrement pour
ces mots de présentation et tout
simplement pour la confiance qu'il me
témoigne au quotidien dans le cadre de
mes fonctions de commissaire dans sa
commission je profite aussi de
l'occasion pour remercier le président
Larcher qui a souhaité une mission sur
les les zones à faible émission ainsi
que le président de mon groupe le
président
Retailleau et le WIP de cette commission
mon collègue Didier Mandelli et comment
ne pas remercier également les
administrateurs qui ont travaillé aux
administratrices parce que j'ai eu la
chance d'avoir trois administratrices à
mes côtés la responsable Stéphanie ainsi
que Carole et Juliette qui ont accompli
un travail remarquable à mes côtés vous
connaissez la qualité du travail des
collaborateurs du Sénat et elles l'ont
trouvé une nouvelle fois à travers leurs
compétences et leur disponibilité
je suis heureux de vous retrouver
aujourd'hui pour vous exposer les
principales conclusions à
recommandations du travail que j'ai eu
l'honneur de conduire en tant que
rapporteur de cette mission
d'information flash relative aux zones à
faible émission qui a été créée en mars
dernier en réponse à un constat partagé
partout elles sont mises en oeuvre les
adefe font l'objet de vivre inquiétudes
et cristallisent un certain nombre de
tensions afin de faire le point sur la
situation et surtout de proposer des
pistes pour améliorer l'acceptabilité du
dispositif j'ai souhaité rencontrer les
principaux acteurs des adefe
collectivités territoriales
usagées aussi bien particulier que
professionnel ONG acteur économiques
administration publique j'ai auditionné
45 organisations réalisées de
déplacements à Strasbourg et à Marseille
qui m'ont permis au total d'échanger
avec 120 personnes concernées par cette
question et j'ai également mis un point
d'honneur à entendre les 11 présidents
ou vice-présidents des agglomérations
ayant mis en place une ZF e en
application de la l'homme afin de
recueillir le retour d'expérience en
outre afin de recueillir le ressenti de
nos concitoyens sur le déploiement de
ses ade j'ai pris l'initiative
d'organiser une consultation en ligne
sur le site du Sénat vous étiez un
certain nombre à être venu à
au moment où nous avons donné les
résultats de cette consultation qui vous
le savez a battu tous les records
puisqu'elle a recueilli plus de 51 000
réponses je ne reviendrai pas sur les
tableaux de cette consultation j'ai eu
l'occasion de vous le dire le 25 mai
dernier enfin j'ai souhaité recourir à
une étude comparée afin d'explorer les
modalités de mise en oeuvre de
dispositifs similaires
retenus par certains pays voisins
j'ouvre une petite parenthèse pour vous
dire que bien sûr à l'issue de mon
intervention vous pourrez avoir le
document l'essentiel qui résumera mon
propos également
incessamment sous peu le rapport qui a
connu encore quelques petites
corrections et probablement l'essentiel
aussi qu'on a dû vous mettre en annexe
de la consultation si vous ne l'aviez
perdu depuis notre rendez-vous du 25 mai
dernier avant toute chose je vous
propose d'évoquer le contexte dans
lequel les EDF ont été institués comme
vous le savez cet outil a été pensé pour
lutter contre la pollution de l'air dans
notre pays les problèmes sanitaires qui
en résultent il est admis que la
pollution atmosphérique déclenche ou
agrafes de nombreuses pathologies
notamment respiratoires cardiovasculaire
et neurologique conduisant à réduire
l'espérance de vie les polluants les
plus dangereux font l'objet d'une
surveillance au niveau national en
particulier les particules fines
auxquelles on attribue 40000 décès par
an en France parmi les personnes âgées
de plus de 30 ans et les oxydes d'azote
les Nox qu'on estime responsable de 7000
morts par an
alors une bonne nouvelle quand même
c'est 20 dernières années la qualité de
l'air c'est nettement améliorée dans
notre pays de nombreux agglomérations
demeurent toutefois confrontés à des
dépassements récurrents des seuils
réglementaires cette situation a donné
lieu à l'engagement de procédure
contentieuse à l'encontre de l'État
français
tu préfères dire la France j'aime pas
trop l'État français parce que ça
rappelle de mauvais souvenirs de notre
histoire
par le Conseil d'État et au niveau
européen par la Cour de justice de
l'Union européenne depuis 2020 la France
a été condamné à verser 30 millions
d'euros d'astreinte du fait de
l'insuffisance des actions engagées pour
lutter contre la pollution de l'air dans
ce contexte la première recommandation
de mon rapport consistera à améliorer
l'information des citoyens sur les
enjeux sanitaires de premier plan
soulevés par la pollution atmosphérique
il me semble que sensibiliser les
concitoyens à ces questions ne peut que
contribuer à améliorer l'acceptabilité
des politiques mises en oeuvre pour
améliorer la qualité de l'air à
commencer par les ZFE pour autant on est
en droit de se questionner sur la
capacité des aidefe à répondre à ces
problématiques de santé publique de
manière efficace trois points me
semblent intéressant à mettre en avant
premièrement si les ZF permettent d'agir
sur les émissions d'oxyde d'azote dont
le transport routier et la source
principale dans notre pays et cela
auteur de
54%. cet outil pourtant apparaît un peu
moins efficace pour réduire l'exposition
particules fines qui sont plus
majoritairement générées par le secteur
résidentiel notamment les chauffages au
bois ainsi que dans une plus faible
mesure par l'agriculture ou l'industrie
deuxièmement la part du transport
routier dans la pollution atmosphérique
peut sensiblement varier selon les
territoires ce qui plaide pour une
approche globale mais aussi
territorialisée pour lutter efficacement
pour la peau pour la pollution de l'air
troisièmement les ADFE à travers le
système de classification critères des
véhicules ne permettent de prendre en
compte que les émissions polluantes
liées au système d'échappement du
véhicule alors qu'une part importante
des émissions de particules est liée au
système de freinage et à l'abrasion des
pneus
au total aujourd'hui les trop tôt pour
évaluer les résultats des élèves mis en
place en France à ce stade ailleurs en
Europe alors que certains présentent des
résultats encourageants d'autres font
part de résultats un petit peu plus
mitigés j'en viens à présent sujet au
vif du sujet le déploiement des adefe en
France comme vous le savez les aidefe
sont les héritières de dispositifs plus
anciens je vais vous éviter les appels
les zcr plusieurs régimes de ZF
coexistent aux côtés des ZFE qui peuvent
être créés à titre facultatif a été
rendu obligatoire la création de ZFE
dans les zones connaissances des
dépassements de normes de qualité de
l'air je le disais tout à l'heure on ZFE
ont ainsi été créés en application de la
l'homme avec des modalités de mise en
oeuvre choisie par chaque agglomération
concernée
la loi climat est résilience que nous
avons adopté il y a deux ans et dont
j'étais le rapporteur sur le volet se
déplacer ajouter deux niveaux
supplémentaires à cet empilement de
régime d'une part elle prévoit dans les
adefes rendus obligatoires en
application de la l'homme et dans
lesquels des dépassements de normes de
qualité de l'air sont encore
enregistrées un schéma précis de
restriction de circulation qui
s'applique et qui consiste à interdire
l'accès à ces zones aux véhicules légers
suivants les véhicules classés critères
5 en 2023 les véhicules
classés critères 4 en 2024 et les
véhicules classés critères 3 en 2025 il
s'agit d'un calendrier qui me semble
dans les conditions actuelles très
précipitées ou trop précipitée j'aurai
l'occasion d'y revenir excusez-moi pour
tous ces détails mais c'est important de
bien comprendre et de bien faire la
distinction je sais que pour la plupart
vous connaissez bien ces sujets mais je
pense qu'il est quand même bien d'avoir
un petit un petit rappel pour un certain
nombre d'entre nous
d'autre part la loi climat est
résilience sera obligatoire la création
avant le 31 décembre 2024 d'une ZF dans
les agglomérations de plus de 150 000
habitants alors quelle est la situation
aujourd'hui comme évoquée précédemment
11 ZF on d'orait déjà été créés 4 à 5
d'entre elles se réconcées par le schéma
de restriction de circulation que je
viens de mentionner à ce jour on
constate un déploiement Nord dispersé
des adefe chacune des agglomérations
concernées à fixer son propre calendrier
d'entrée en vigueur de restriction pour
tenir compte des situations et des
enjeux propres à chaque territoire alors
c'est intéressant mais certains
mettre l'accent sur les véhicules légers
d'autres sur les véhicules lourds sur
les deux ou trois roues quelquefois 7
jours sur 7 24 heures sur 24 pour
certains usagers professionnels les
choses sont différentes
cette hétérogénéité
pose un certain nombre de problèmes pour
le transport de marchandises notamment
comme vous l'imaginez et en complexe le
déplacement d'une ZFE à une autre cette
situation ne devrait pas s'améliorer
compte tenu de l'obligation de la
création de ZF supplémentaires par la
loi climat et résilience d'ici 2025 je
le disais à l'instant 11 ZF loi
d'orientation des mobilités
trentaine 32 33 34 on sait pas
exactement supplémentaire dans le cadre
de la loi climat et résilience au total
donc plus d'une quarantaine
d'agglomération devrait être concernés
ce qui pourrait à terme nuire davantage
à la lisibilité du dispositif je pense
notamment à des gens qui vont connaître
la concentration de 6 ADFE à quelques
kilomètres qui sont les régions des
Hauts-de-France et d'Auvergne
Rhône-Alpes aussi afin d'anticiper le
déploiement à plus grande échelle du
dispositif et pour permettre une mise en
œuvre concerté des adefe en cours avec
celle à venir nous allons vous proposer
d'organiser des conférences régionales
pour permettre une meilleure
articulation des dispositifs entre eux
ça veut pas dire une harmonisation
totale et des règles communes peut-être
un référentiel commun en tout cas tout
le monde se met autour de la table
probablement sous l'égide du préfet de
région pour essayer de rendre
aux artisans au transport de
marchandises et même aux particuliers la
vie plus simple dans cette coordination
indispensable
cela étant dit les aider feux étant un
outil de santé publique je rappelle que
c'est une politique qui relève de la
responsabilité de l'État à la santé
publique leur déploiement par les
collectivités territoriales devraient en
toute logique pour voir s'appuyer sur un
réel accompagnement de l'État beaucoup
d'agglomérations nous ont indiqué que
cet accompagnement n'était pas au
rendez-vous que ce soit en matière
d'information que ce soit en matière de
soutien financier en matière de contrôle
de telle sorte que plusieurs d'entre
elles ont le sentiment d'être un peu
abandonnés ou en première ligne pour
mettre en place ce dispositif
et cela de manière transpartisane je
tiens le préciser au-delà de ce défaut
d'accompagnement de l'État que l'on peut
regretter la mise en oeuvre des ZFE pose
plusieurs difficultés majeures en
premier lieu les restrictions de
circulation en vigueur surtout celles à
venir en application du schéma loi
climat et résilient sont susceptibles de
concerner à court terme ou plus
exactement d'ici un an et demi environ
un tiers du parc automobile national
or cela me conduit à au second point le
renouvellement d'un tel nombre de
véhicules alors c'est un chiffre très
approximatif mais qui est quand même
assez proche de la réalité de 13
millions dans des délais aussi contrats
supposent une très forte accélération du
rythme d'évolution du parc observer ces
10 dernières années mais qui semble
matériellement peu réaliste
outre la question de la disponibilité
celle du coût des véhicules et centrales
je parle même pas de lavitaillement
concernant les véhicules électriques à
ce jour et malgré les aides déjà
existantes le reste à charge pour les
ménages comme pour les professionnels
restent souvent trop élevés pour
permettre un verdissement du parc dans
de tels dans ce contexte le dispositif
tel qu'il existe aujourd'hui présente un
risque de creusement des fractures
sociales et territoriales les crânes que
nous avions formulées ici même il y a
deux ans lors de climat est résilience
semble aujourd'hui ce matérialiser en
l'état la mise en oeuvre des ZFE dans
des délais aussi serrés et sans
accompagnement suffisant et de nature à
faire porter la contrainte
prioritairement sur les ménages les plus
modestes et je souhaiterais m'arrêter un
instant sur un exemple que nous avons
vécu à Marseille lors de notre visite je
vous rappellerai que le troisième
arrondissement de Marseille qui est le
plus pauvre de France qui se situe en
pleine ZFE
[Musique]
a dans son parc de véhicules 52% de ces
mêmes véhicules qui sont classés
critères 5 4 ou 3
52% de véhicules
critères 5 4 ou 3 ça veut dire 52% des
véhicules qui selon la loi aujourd'hui
ne pourrait plus circuler dans Marseille
d'ici un an et demi en août les ZFE
contrainte rond sans doute davantage la
mobilité des usagers éloignés des
centres vides qui ne disposent pas
d'alternatives suffisantes et qui de
fait son plus dépendant de leur véhicule
alors que la hausse des prix de
l'immobilier a bien souvent conduit ses
ménages à résider hors des
agglomérations et dans des zones où les
transports collectifs sont souvent moins
denses leur interdire l'accès lorsqu'ils
souhaitent s'y rendre pour travailler et
pour leur loisirs pourraient aussi
s'apparenter à une triple peine je
précise de mémoire que ce sont 50% des
personnes qui qui viennent travailler en
ZFE qui habite à l'extérieur des ZFE en
moyenne pour répondre à ces difficultés
la Commission à adopter trois axes de
proposition le premier axe consiste à
accélérer le verdissement du parc de
véhicules routiers à travers trois
leviers premièrement renforcer les aides
à l'acquisition de véhicules propres
neufs d'une par il s'agit de renforcer
de mieux cibler le bonus écologique et
la prime à la conversion qui existe de
manière significative au bénéfice des
ménages modestes et résidant à distance
des agglomérations c'est un sujet qui me
tient particulièrement à cœur puisqu'on
s'est aperçu que des personnes qui
habitaient hors ZFE n'était pas aidés
par les métropoles concernées d'autre
part nous proposons de généraliser le
prêt à taux zéro que nous avions déjà
voté cher président lors de climat et
résidence qu'il avait été retenu en CMP
pour une simple expérimentation de deux
ans qui d'ailleurs n'arrive même pas à
se mettre en place nous souhaitons
pérenniser ce dispositif
après à taux zéro garantie par l'État
pour l'acquisition de véhicules propres
léger
dans le même ordre d'idées nous
recommandons de créer un prêt à taux
zéro spécifique sur les véhicules lourds
propres comme déjà proposé lors de
climat est résilience deuxièmement il
est indispensable d'encourager
développement du marché d'occasion je
j'ouvre une parenthèse aussi je
questionnerais le ministre Béchu sur ce
sujet cet après-midi et je lui
demanderai aussi où en est le projet
gouvernemental de leasing social où on a
du mal les uns et les autres j'imagine
avoir des informations sur l'avancée de
ce dispositif
ingénieux fort généreux mais dont on n'a
pas beaucoup d'informations à l'heure où
on parle
j'aimerais pouvoir oui encourager le
développement du marché de l'occasion
pour les véhicules propres vous savez
que les aides aujourd'hui bénéficient
tu l'électrique mais j'aimerais qu'elle
puisse bénéficier au marché d'occasion
également
et notamment aux vignettes critères 1
pour permettre le cas échéant
une étape supplémentaire et beaucoup
moins lourde financièrement pour
certains nombre de nos concitoyens et
bien sûr le recours au rétrophytes
rétrofit plus compliqué pour les
voitures de particuliers mais plutôt
bien avancé en termes de technologie
pour pour les vues ou pour les camions
c'est l'objet de plusieurs propositions
avec un bonus écologique véhicule
d'occasion classe etc intégration du
rétrofit sur le sur amortissement vert
pour les entreprises etc troisièmement
nombre d'acteurs entendus critiquent la
complexité la manque de lisibilité du
système d'aide à l'acquisition actuelle
qui repose sur une multiplicité de
dispositifs au niveau national et local
cela se traduit par un phénomène assez
frustrant qui est le phénomène du non
recours au Z pour remédier à cela la
commission vous avez 50% des personnes
qui ont droit à des aides et qui ne les
utilisent pas qui ne les demande pas ou
qui ne savent pas où les demander d'où
l'idée alors qu'il vous paraît
traditionnel parce qu'on en entend
souvent parler mais là c'est l'exemple
que c'est indispensable nous souhaitons
un guichet unique alors plutôt au niveau
des régions parce que les régions
maintenant ont une compétence au niveau
économique et ont un certain nombre de
guichets uniques quel que soit voilà le
niveau qui est choisi il est
indispensable pour permettre
l'utilisation
et le phénomène pour lutter contre le
phénomène de non recours aux aides pour
des personnes qui en ont vraiment besoin
le remplacement de l'ensemble des
véhicules les plus polluants par des
véhicules propres n'est pas en soi
recherché ne règlera pas par exemple la
problématique de la congestion
les zones affaiblissement doivent être
pensées dans une politique plus globale
de mobilité donc ça c'est l'objet du
deuxième axe puisque l'objectif mais on
en parle dans ce rapport c'est bien sûr
d'utiliser des alternatives à l'usage de
la voiture autour de deux leviers créer
un véritable choc et j'utilise le terme
des ça d'un choc d'offre alternative de
transport à l'auto sollisme c'est bien
sûr ce qui existe déjà
avec la création de Paul deschanges
multimodo de services de carré Express
qui peut être une bonne solution et puis
le développement des services express
régionaux métropolita qu'on appelait les
RER Macron il y a quelques temps et qui
sont en train de se transformer que nous
attendons au Sénat soit avant la fin de
la session soit au tout début de la de
la prochaine session pour pouvoir
permettre
d'accélérer l'offre et d'augmenter
l'offre au niveau des transports en
commun et dans le quelque chose et je
sais que le président Longeot est très
attaché à ça aussi l'abaissement du taux
de TVA 5 5 sur les transports collectifs
que nous avions décidé voté plusieurs
fois au Sénat parce que nous considérons
que cela pourra aider à certains noms
d'autorités organisatrices de mobilité à
être plus offensive dans son dans son
offre et pourquoi pas répercuter aussi
sur le la tarification
cet air que pourrait donner cette
abaissement de la TVA à 5,5
tel un produit de première nécessité
également des réflexions et notamment
suivant un exemple que nous avons pu
entendre à Bruxelles la création pour
certains ménages d'un budget mobilité en
échange de la mise au rebut d'un
véhicule polluant qui pourrait être
utilisé sur le mode de transport mode ou
vélo transport en commun
utilisé par la par la personne selon son
choix j'en arrive au troisième et du
rapport assouplir le calendrier de
restriction de circulation nous vous
proposons deux mesures une première
mesure qui est de rationaliser le
calendrier d'entrée en vigueur des
interdictions de circulation qui
apparaissent irréaliste du fait des
changes trop d'échéance pardon trop
rapprochés contenu des difficultés
rencontrées tant par les 11 ZF déjà
institués que par celles à venir nous
proposons de rendre le calendrier actuel
tout simplement plus réaliste on peut se
faire plaisir en disant oui le
calendrier soit tenu ça ne sera pas le
cas c'est clairement pour avoir été sur
les territoires pour pouvoir échanger
avec les responsables des des métropoles
totalement
irréalistes donc moi je propose un
calendrier qui soit plus réaliste à
travers trois leviers repousser à 2030
au plus tard et le haut plus tard est
important l'entrée en vigueur des
restrictions de circulation concernant
les véhicules class des critères 3 pour
les
territoires qui sont prêts qui
souhaitent le réaliser et qui pensent
que la population est prête à opérer
cette transition et abandonner leur
véhicule critères 3 sont la possibilité
de le faire mais pour ceux qui pensent
comme nous que sous un an et demi il est
totalement impossible de supprimer un
véhicule sur deux sur certains
territoires
on veut être plus transparent et moins
rêveur sur les objectifs et se pose bien
sûr la question de des contrôles qui
devront venir un jour ou l'autre de
toutes les manières que ce soit l'état
ou les collectivités c'est la raison
pour laquelle on pense qu'il est plus
sain de repousser par souci de
transparence et de lisibilité à 2030 au
plus tard l'entrée en vigueur
pour ces ZF l'homme des critères 3
fixer au 1er janvier 2030 également donc
repoussé de 5 années la date butoir pour
la création des autres ZFE celle de
d'agglomération de 150 000 habitants qui
étaient proposés dans climat est
résilience et là de toutes les manières
c'est ce qu'on avait déjà voté au Sénat
donc ça ne change rien on considère là
aussi et on a eu un retour de des
échanges de questionnaires des la
quarantaine de présidents concernés la
plupart ne se voit pas mettre en place
une ZFE dès 2025 pour autant ceux qui en
ont la volonté peuvent le faire à
travers leur pouvoir de police à travers
des aménagements urbains qu'ils ont
compétences pour mettre en place que ce
soit des zones 30 dans leur dans leur
centre-ville que ce soit par la
suppression d'un certain nombre de feux
rouges qui sont sources quelquefois de
ce qu'on nous a dit de pollution ou donc
l'idée c'est vraiment de pouvoir laisser
la main trajectoire m'éclate butoir ne
soit plus de 25 mais de 30 pour pouvoir
s'organiser enfin dans l'ensemble de ces
ZFE mais elles sont venues d'elles-mêmes
à ce à ce à ce résultat à part deux
d'entre elles qui ont proposé des
clauses de revoyure le report est
notamment pour les véhicules lourds des
critères d'eux en gros du diesel
jusqu'en 2030
autant les choses évoluent plutôt
positivement pour rendre le parc plus
proche
au niveau des véhicules de particuliers
autant au niveau des véhicules lourds
notamment tous les véhicules de de
concernant les le bâtiment concernant
le transport de marchandises concernant
les forains concernant on en a vu
beaucoup je peux vous dire que la
technologie et le coût des des véhicules
des carbonés et largement trop important
financièrement et intenables pour
pouvoir supprimer en 2000 avant 2030 les
critères de donc la fin du diesel les
exemples européens montrent aussi
et ça c'est ce qui m'a particulièrement
intéressé dans l'étude de droit comparé
dans les auditions que nous avons eu
avec d'autres pays c'est la
progressivité du calendrier c'est ça la
clé de la réussite
pourquoi on parle de les exemples
étrangers ils ont commencé avant nous et
ils terminent après nous exemple
Bruxelles 18 ans pour mener à bien ce
calendrier nous on est sur cinq ans
voilà j'en dirai pas plus enfin compte
tenu des contraintes qui pèsent sur le
renouvellement du parc de véhicules nous
proposons une mesure d'accompagnement
qui est pragmatique
alors qui peut se substituer le cas
échéant sur par rapport à la précédente
proposition si le gouvernement ne
retient pas notre volonté de voir le
calendrier être un peu retardé tout
simplement par honnêteté intellectuelle
et transparence c'est de dire qu'il y
aurait la possibilité
de prendre des mesures d'accompagnement
pour individualiser le système de
vignette critères en fonction du degré
d'entretien des véhicules parce que le
l'entretien du véhicule et le degré
d'entretien de ce même véhicule peut
avoir une incidence non négligeable sur
la quantité de polluants émises nous
souhaitons renforcer le contrôle des
émissions polluantes dans le cadre d'un
contrôle technique qui serait voilà
concomit avec le contrôle technique de
sécurité obligatoire et qui pourrait
permettre de récompenser les
comportements vertueux et aux personnes
qui entretiennent bien leur véhicule et
qui n'est pas plus polluant un peu plus
polluant et même moins polluants qu'un
véhicule critère un lourd avec des gros
pneus usés
de pouvoir être
exonéré de l'application des vignettes
critères et d'avoir une espérance de vie
de quelques années limitées mais de
quelques années supplémentaires ça c'est
une mesure pour individualiser les
choses voilà comme je l'ai dit mettre 15
millions de véhicules à la casse en
moins d'un an et demi quand on nous
demande de dans notre domicile d'essayer
de donner une deuxième vie quelquefois
chers président à notre télévision voir
un autre machine à laver de les faire
réparer plutôt que de les jeter dans
l'acheter une autre je pense que pour
les véhicules ça pourrait être un petit
peu la même chose si bien sûr ces
véhicules répondent aux critères des
centres de contrôle qui
avec des nouvelles technologies arrivent
à contrôler ou arriveront à contrôler
dans les mois qui viennent la
consommation en tout cas la production
de particules fines ou de dioxyde
d'azote
dans les pots d'échappement des
véhicules vignettes critères 3 par
exemple voilà j'en ai terminé pour une
présentation de ce de ce rapport que
vous aurez qui a une centaine de pages
avec que vous avez alors ça c'est un
dossier de presse vous avez l'essentiel
à l'intérieur également peut-être les
deux essentielles celui de la dernière
fois et celui là vous avez
également toutes les personnes qu'on a
eu l'occasion de d'auditionner en annexe
je pense en tout cas si vous le
souhaitez nous pouvons vous les faire
parvenir et vous verrez que le travail
je l'espère a été
intéressant pour nous je l'espère
complet le plus objectif possible sans a
priori et en essayant de relater au
maximum la situation telle qu'on l'a
perçue et avec des propositions qui nous
paraissent raisonnables et qui je
l'espère seront repris par le
gouvernement ce sera peut-être une de
vos questions mais je vais me permettre
de la devancer à 15h je sais pas 15h
combien
l'ordre des questions gouvernement n'est
pas sortie mais à 15h et quelques ou en
tout cas entre 15h et 16h30 j'aurai
l'occasion de poser une question au
ministre
déchu pour lui demander ce qu'il compte
faire quand il en aura pris connaissance
de ce rapport sénatorial que j'aurais
qualifié d'excellence si ce n'était pas
le mien
je plaisante voilà est-ce que je peux
répondre à vos questions
est-ce que vous permettez que j'enlève
la veste parce qu'il fut relativement
assez chaud et puis à votre disposition
la tribune concrètement comment ça va se
traduire si c'est repris c'est est-ce
qu'il faut une ppm il faut du changement
des décrets d'application de la loi
climatériences pour modifier les dates
concrètement comment ça pourrait être
amélioré dans les 9 recommandations il y
a un petit peu de tout il y a des alors
je parle vraiment sous le contrôle de je
sais pas une connaissance suffisamment
fine de de ces questions et je parle
sous le contrôle de nos administrateurs
mais il y a des préconisations du
rapport qui sont réglementaires qui
peuvent être adaptés et mise en place
immédiatement il y en a qui sont plus
législatives
qui peuvent peut-être pour un certain
nombre d'entre elles également être voté
à travers les lois de finances qui
peuvent le permettre donc voilà dans les
recommandations il y a il y a un petit
peu de un petit peu de tout au niveau au
niveau réglementaire ou législatif après
voilà je demande pas au gouvernement de
strictosensus de reprendre nos 9
recommandations il y en a quelques-unes
en plus qui peuvent se substituer à à
d'autres mais voilà il y a des mesures
de nature
législatives qui peuvent peut-être
arriver aussi sur un certain nombre de
textes qu'on peut avoir sur les
mobilités comme on en a assez
régulièrement ou bien de manière
réglementaire assez rapidement s'il le
souhaite
qui peut me servir d'antisèche ouais
c'est ça
voilà par exemple critère de tout ce qui
touche au bonus écologique et
réglementaire le PTZ et le rapport du
calendrier est un petit peu plus
législatif
oui
du moniteur DTP vous avez parlé de
plébiscite plus précisément qui qui a
voté président
les votes de ce matin l'ensemble des
commissaires
des républicains ont voté pour le texte
bon c'est bien ils avaient intérêt à le
faire
je plaisante non non ils l'ont fait dans
leur ensemble l'ensemble des
commissaires de l'Union centriste aussi
et
l'ensemble du groupe socialiste
qui a voté également pour le texte nous
avons eu de mémoire de deux abstentions
de
d'abstention bienveillante telle qu'elle
a été exprimée du des représentants
communistes et nous avons eu de votre
compte de
des vers
dont
un qui a reconnu qu'il aurait voté 7 des
9 mesures
mais je ne pouvais pas les saucissonner
oui
est-ce que votre rapport contient des
préconisations particulières pour les
véhicules anciens autrement dit les plus
tôt les véhicules de collection depuis
30 ans qui sont peut-être pas loin mais
qui parcourt des distances plutôt
faibles chaque année non alors là
c'est le
collègue du président l'engin
Jean-Pierre Moga qui vous a envoyé pour
la question c'est ça d'accord non non je
plaisante je plaisante non alors
concernant
concernant principalement la question de
toutes les dérogations la mare reste au
territoire c'est à dire que nous on n'a
pas cherché à s'immiscer
dans dans les choix que les
territoires ont fait notamment sur tout
ce qui touche au dérogation il y a des
dérogations par exemple il y a des il y
a des agglomérations qui mettent en
place des passes pour les petits
rouleurs il y a des il y a des
agglomérations qui mettent en place
des passes 24 passes à l'année voilà
pour pour pouvoir circuler en ZF même si
vous n'avez pas la bonne vignette
critères et certaines agglomérations
décidé d'exempter les véhicules de
collection sous certains critères la
date peut-être de fonctionnement de la
voiture ou autre la main reste au
territoire et quand j'ai parlé d'une
certaine coordination c'est pas que je
veux revenir en arrière c'est simplement
c'est pas tant le problème des voitures
de collection mais plus pour le
transport notamment de marchandises qui
est une coordination au sein de la
région pour que les règles et les
référentiels soient quand même communs
ou en tout cas quand il y a une demande
de dérogation pour une ZFE de la région
si elle est accordée elle puisse
fonctionner pour pour tous les autres
voilà c'est c'est simplement là-dessus
par contre la main reste au territoire
et chaque territoire a déjà en lien avec
les associations
accepté je pense des dérogations dans un
cas de spécifique ça peut être sur des
week-ends ça peut être voilà il y a en
tout cas des règles très décentralisées
qui existent sur les territoires et qui
sont
qui ont fonctionné plutôt bien
globalement quand même dans la
concertation quand je parlais de manque
de concertation et d'informations elle
s'est relativement bien elle a été bien
réalisée sur les territoires c'est plus
au niveau de l'État qu'elle a qu'elle
est absente voilà on a on a visité
notamment à Strasbourg l'agence du
climat qui va
visiter les personnes pour leur
expliquer les aidefe comment ça
fonctionne quand comment pourquoi voilà
donc ça se fait plutôt bien sur les
territoires avec tous
beaucoup moins au niveau de l'État
oui
pardon alors madame madame perron
vous me demandez vous me dites bonjour
bonjour
avec vos préconisations propositions que
va-t-il advenir des 11 déjà existants et
des 32 nouvelles doivent-elles revoir
leur copie pour une meilleure
coordination comme souhaité alors non
elle continue à elle continue leur vie
c'est à dire que les règles qui ont été
mises en place notamment pour les 11
premières de supprimer pour la plupart
d'entre elles pour toutes les critères 5
pour la plupart d'entre elles pas toutes
mais les critères 4
continuent à fonctionner pour celles qui
souhaitent
accélérer ou qui ont souhaité accélérer
le calendrier elles ont pu le faire
simplement arrivant à l'échéance elles
sont revenues pour la plupart en arrière
donc elles ont toujours cette liberté de
faire simplement pour celles qui
s'inquiètent
de l'obligation de reporter
d'appliquer la
l'interdiction des critères 3 dans un an
et demi elles ont la possibilité de
lisser cette décision sur le temps ça
peut être 2026 2027 2028 2029 et ça peut
aller au maximum jusqu'à 2030 et pour
les 30 de nouvelles théoriques
là aussi si elle souhaite le faire comme
c'était prévu au 1er janvier elles
peuvent très bien mettre en place leurs
zones affaiblissement elles ont les
pouvoirs de police pour le faire par
contre celle qui demande plus de temps
pour informer pour concerter pourquoi
ordonner elles auront si notre
proposition est retenue
jusque
au 1er janvier 2030 pour la mettre en
place
pour Ouest-France je voulais j'avais
d'autres petites questions une très très
pratique sur les
vous avez évoqué la généralisation du
prêt à taux zéro garanti par l'État pour
le l'échange de véhicules d'occasion
pour l'achat d'un véhicule d'occasion en
fait est-ce que ça c'est les mêmes
conditions que pour l'achat d'un
molécule 9 - polluants ça c'est les
mêmes critères alors et seconde question
j'avais sur les contrôles vous avez
évoqué la question des contrôles dans
les rencontres que vous avez eu sur le
terrain est-ce que c'est un sujet
d'inquiétude pour les pour les
présidents d'agglos alors concernant la
question des des aides oui on
souhaiterait que que les aides les
principales aides qui sont le bonus
écologique alors dans un moindre un mois
de niveau la prime à la casse mais le
bonus écologique qui de mémoire
représente plus d'un milliard
l'idée c'est
de changer un certain nombre de critères
comme je vous l'ai dit c'est de
permettre
aux ménage les plus modestes dans
bénéficier à un taux plus important
qu'aujourd'hui
et pour que ce soit pratiquement un
moyen constant
ceux qui n'en n'ont pas besoin et qu'ils
l'ont automatiquement sont très très
heureux que ça puisse profiter à
quelqu'un qui en a vraiment besoin
et deuxièmement qu'on puisse le proposer
aussi de manière
supérieure plus importante aux personnes
qui sont hors ZFE parce qu'elles ne sont
pas aidées elles par les métropoles qui
n'ont pas compétences pour
aider des personnes qui sont hors de
leur territoire et quand je dis hors des
ZFE c'est hors des ZFE en résidence mais
ce sont des personnes qui viennent
travailler dans les feux c'est là c'est
la
l'obligation quand même de pouvoir
bénéficier de ces aides donc on a essayé
et vous le verrez dans le rapport c'est
très détaillé ça va être long de tout
expliquer mais l'idée c'est vraiment
d'accès ménage plus modeste les ménages
qui qui sont hors des ZF mais qui
viennent travailler dans les aidefe et
aujourd'hui de permettre aussi pour ceux
qui ne peuvent pas aller à l'électrique
immédiatement pour des raisons
financières d'aller sur un marché
d'occasion critères
a qui qui peut permettre de faire cette
transition et puis de toute manière
l'offre aujourd'hui n'existe pas n'est
pas suffisamment importante sur
l'électrique donc il y a des voitures
qui ont une espérance de vie plus ou
moins longues c'est le cas pour les
vignettes critères 1 donc c'est
important d'ouvrir ce marché à
l'occasion et de donner un bonus
écologique pour les personnes qui
remplaceraient leur vignette critères
vignette 5 4 ou 3 pour aller sur du
et la question du contrôle pardon la
question du contrôle je vais vous le
dire très franchement je reconnais que
dans le rapport vous ne trouverez rien
de
je dirais pas de recommandation
concrètes là dessus la seule
recommandation que que qu'on peut avoir
c'est que l'État et les collectivités se
mettent d'accord là-dessus voilà moi je
veux pas dire qui doit faire quoi mais
en gros l'État depuis 4 ans
laisse espérer la mise en place de
lecture automatique des plaques
ils auraient lancé je parle aux
conditionnel un appel d'offre à ce sujet
et mettrez à disposition au deuxième
semestre 24 c'est ce dispositif aux
agglomérations qu'ils le souhaitent
on va parler à l'instant politique
est-ce que vous êtes persuadé que par
exemple en 2025 la veille des
municipales
certains certaines agglomérations soient
très enclins à installer des radars pour
la lecture
des plaques et pour les PV qui vont avec
alors pour essayer de convaincre les
collectivités de le faire l'état dit on
vous fournit les radars vous les payez
quand même mais à travers le fond vert
fond vert 150 millions sur les ZFE
pratiquement 80 millions déjà de
d'engager ou de consommer je sais pas si
ça suffira et Royal l'État leur laisse
quand même les bénéfices des
des amendes de potentiel tout ça pour
vous dire que d'un autre côté les
collectivités ont pas très envie vous
nous dites que c'est un problème de
santé publique la santé publique c'est
l'état c'est à vous de contrôler nous en
plus les agglomérations on n'a pas de
pouvoir de police
voilà donc il y a un vrai problème
aujourd'hui sur la question du contrôle
je suis français vous êtes français
quand il y a pas de contrôle en France
c'est pas de manière très spontanée
on respecte ou qu'on anticipe les règles
donc voilà cette question va continuer à
se poser et les uns et les autres
devront trancher prendre leur
responsabilité parce que je l'ai dit ce
matin au collègue vert qui n'ont pas
souhaité voter la mesure où pour un
d'entre eux je lui ai dit c'est facile
de dire garder le calendrier par contre
tant qu'il tant que ça ne sera pas
effectif de manière concrète
vous n'allez pas sauver plus de vie
parce que vous interdisez les vignettes
critères on le voit tous les présidents
d'agglo nous disent les quelques
contrôles qui sont opérés ce sont des
contrôles annexes c'est à dire que quand
vous allez contrôler quelqu'un pour une
autre infraction
tu as dépassé la vitesse conduite en
état débriété il y a un contrôle qui
sera fait de peut-être ou non de la
vignette critère Monsieur Estrosi qu'on
a auditionné ici nous dit c'est une
mesure d'État c'est santé publique moi
ma police municipale contrôlera pas les
vignettes critères voilà je donne
quelques exemples sur le sur la
difficulté du contrôle et
sur le fait que l'État et les
collectivités doivent avancer
probablement sur ce sujet mais moi je ne
me suis n'écoutant que mon courage qui
ne me disait rien je me suis abstenu de
me prononcer sur ce sujet dans le
rapport parce que j'ai pas de la bonne
solution si les uns et les autres ne
peuvent pas leur responsabilité
il fonctionne
du coup vous allez faire poser une
question à Monsieur Béchu tout à l'heure
et je suppose lui parler de votre
rapport je voulais savoir est-ce que
vous avez eu aussi des contacts avec
Anne-Marie Jean et Jean-Luc Moutin qui
ont été chargés du comité de
concertation en début d'année qui eux
aussi ont bien avancé sur leurs travaux
et est-ce que vous ne craignez pas que
vos propositions arrivent un peu tard et
ne soit pas prise en compte dans leur
propositions qui feront au ministre cet
été non c'est les leurs qui vont arriver
un petit peu tard
je crois qu'il y a eu des conférences et
des conférences et des conférences
qu'est-ce qu'il en ressort moi j'ai
l'impression que le gouvernement
souhaitait gagner du temps et que comme
par hasard c'est quand on a lancé notre
mission flash que le calendrier
de
des personnes qui ont été mandatées par
le gouvernement c'est accélérer de
manière incroyable donc j'en suis ravi
si ça a pu au moins servir à ça par
contre concernant Monsieur moudinck et
Madame Jean ce sont des gens compétents
qui connaissent très bien le sujet que
nous avons eu l'occasion de
d'auditionner et je ne doute pas un
instant qu'il feront un certain nombre
de propositions moi j'ai pas et je sais
que le président Longeot le président
l'archet le président Retailleau sont
sont dans cet état d'esprit on veut rien
revendiquer moi je veux pas la marque le
tampon du Sénat sur une recommandation
approuvé labellisée par le je veux que
les choses avancent sur les zones à
faibles émission j'ai conscience de ce
problème de santé publique mais d'un
autre côté j'ai conscience que qu'il y a
une accès une inacceptabilité sociale
qui règne aujourd'hui dans mon pays et
j'ai pas encore envie de revoir des des
gilets jaunes bloqués le pays de voir de
la de la violence sur certains
territoires des manifestations comme on
envoie le plus en plus souvent notamment
sur le secteur de Rouen et et bientôt
dans d'autres secteurs si des mesures ne
sont pas prises qu'elles soient prises
suite à des recommandations monsieur
moudin ou madame jean ou soit de Madame
Pompili aussi qui est maintenant une
mission sur le sujet ou bien de notre
rapport j'ai aucun droit d'auteur sur
sur cet excellent rapport et et il sera
utilisé je l'espère et si c'est pas le
cas
à l'identique j'ai trouvé des mesures
intéressantes sur le rapport le seul et
Emilienne également que repris dans le
rapport parce que la question m'a été
posée j'allais pas plagier le travail et
les propositions intéressantes qu'ils
ont pu faire donc vraiment le principal
c'est qu'on avance sur ces adefe et
qu'on puisse de nouveau et je pense que
c'est un vrai objectif qu'on peut se
fixer même s'il y a une amélioration de
la qualité de l'air dans notre pays
depuis un certain nombre d'années si on
arrive à réconcilier qualité de l'air
avec à acceptabilité sociale on aura
collectivement rempli notre mission
alors quand même des questions
j'ai été frappé
depuis une petite semaine alors attendez
alors
000 euros seulement aujourd'hui ne
serait pas non plus une solution pour
les Français ayant des revenus modestes
oui on enverra les préconisations à
Automoto enfin le rapport à Monsieur
Dupont il y a un certain nombre de
propositions également donc sur des
majorations de bonus sur ces questions
et puis bien sûr on prend
on compte tout ce qui touche au rétrofit
et notamment c'est le l'éthanol 85 là
que je vois c'est ça voilà tout à fait
et le GPL oui oui tout ce qui touche au
rétrofit figure dans le dans le rapport
monsieur Dupont on enverra automatique
tous ces éléments
oui
je voudrais revenir sur les annonces du
gouvernement d'octobre 2022 ils avaient
parlé aussi de lancer une grande
communication nationale au premier
octobre 2022 vous m'avez redonné la date
travail très vite octobre 2022 et
on va avoir les conclusions parce que on
a accéléré un petit peu nous notre
calendrier maintenant tant mieux et le
gouvernement vous avez d'ailleurs aussi
aux réserve un débat avec Christophe
BECHU et en janvier je crois sur ce
sujet ils avaient annoncé une grande
communication de campagne de
communication au niveau national au
premier semestre on est mi-juin est-ce
que vous avez des nouvelles de ça ou pas
pas vraiment moi j'ai rien vu sur la
aussi on a eu deux coordinateurs
interministériels sur le sujet et de
remettre mini puis le deuxième on
connaît pas encore le nom sauf les
initiés est-ce que ça veut dire que
c'est un sujet inextricable ou que
[Musique]
quand on peut s'en sortir par le
collectivement Etap parlementaire
collectivité et citoyens moi je vous dis
qu'on a réussi notre mission c'est
d'avoir accéléré un petit peu les choses
je suis déjà content de ça je sais pas
cher Jean-François qu'est-ce qui sera
repris mais déjà ça accéléré les choses
comme vous l'avez dit deux coordinateurs
le premier on l'a reçu dans le cadre de
notre de notre mission flash
24 heures après on nous dit c'est plus
lui bon ça peut ça peut arriver et bon
on a pas eu l'occasion de pouvoir
recontacter le nouveau
voilà le calendrier avancé j'ai
l'impression qu'il y avait une volonté
de de laisser retomber les choses après
à la décharge du gouvernement il y a
quelques sujets sociaux aussi dans le
pays en ce moment ou en tout cas ces
derniers mois qui ont animé l'agenda de
tous les partenaires mais mais je pense
que voilà l'idée c'est de pouvoir
continuer à avancer la formation
l'information mon information je sais
très bien que l'État et je l'ai dit
d'ailleurs au collègue ce matin quand
l'État veut communiquer il sait très
bien le faire il a les moyens
et deuxièmement
le front de manière plutôt pertinente
quand vous avez un spot télévisé
ou des encarts pris dans dans la presse
écrite ou sur des médias internet qui
sont particulièrement
marquants et bienfaits ça vaut toutes
les informations possibles j'ai voilà il
y a des spots et j'imagine
malheureusement j'imaginerai très bien
un spot qui pourrait montrer ce que la
pollution
atmosphérique alors pas que du fait de
je le rappelle de de la route mais
également de l'industrie des chauffages
à bois et autres mais susceptibles de
causer si vous mettez un enfant qui
ouvre sur le périph sa fenêtre et qui
commence à faire une crise d'asthme vous
allez sensibiliser les les concitoyens à
ce qui est une réalité c'est pas voilà
ça ça existe c'est pas inventé c'est pas
surjoué ça existe les chiffres qui vous
ont été donnés les particules fines
c'est 40 000 j'ai parlé des 7000 sur les
Nox mais 40 000 sur les particules fines
il y a beaucoup de maladies qui qui sont
la conséquence de ça si vous montrez des
images choc voilà on a tous aussi en
mémoire des spots sur sur l'alcool au
volant sur toutes ces questions
quand ils veulent ils peuvent et je leur
reproche de ne pas l'avoir fait parce
qu'on est rentré dans une confusion où
les personnes pensent qu'on est sur des
sujets uniquement climatiques c'est un
sujet important aussi la protection de
la planète la couche d'ozone mais mais
c'est quand même un sujet distinct voilà
vous vous pensez pas sauver peut-être
l'humanité en changeant de voiture par
contre comme c'est fait en Belgique
quand vous contrôlez en bas de chez vous
dans l'école de votre fils le taux de
pollution comme ça se fait dans ce pays
là ça a tout de suite voilà vous y êtes
confronté de manière directe ça vous
marque et ça vous fait réfléchir
oui
prévenez-moi quand il y a des questions
gouvernement parce que je vais avoir
l'air bête de pas poser la question
alors quand tu me dis vous avez parlé
des 13 millions de véhicules légers
impacté d'ici 2025 dans le texte actuel
est-ce que vous avez calculé l'impact au
spécifique aux véhicules utilitaires des
artisans en nombre de véhicules en
impact financier il est beaucoup plus
important parce que la
voilà la
production et la l'acquisition alors
aujourd'hui de mémoire
les vulles il y en a 6 millions dans
notre pays donc si
le diesel est interdit ils sont 100%
diesel si le diesel est interdit voilà
vous imaginez le alors de mémoire il y a
peut-être mesdames ça doit être 2%
environ de de bulles qui ne sont pas au
diesel mais mais le reste le le
son certains territoires souhaitent
interdire le diesel encore pour
l'instant que ce sera Lyon ou Strasbourg
en 2028 en 2028 j'imagine que
voilà les 6 millions de vues ne pourront
pas être remplacés en dehors du fait
aussi qui a
voilà quand vous avez une énorme
entreprise qui doit changer sa flotte
allez je vais dire ça fait jamais
plaisir notamment quand elle est cinq
fois plus chère en terme de coût mais il
y a des entreprises qui ont les reins
pour pour pouvoir amortir ça sur un
certain nombre d'années après un petit
artisan il peut pas le faire de manière
aussi facile et on a rencontré des
associations
de
d'artisans qui nous disent qui
refusaient des petits marchés publics
dans des villes qui sont en ZFE
aujourd'hui
alors écoutez si il n'y a j'ai vu que le
maître de
l'horloge et du temps me dit que
voilà vous voyez c'est 6 millions de
vues mais il y en a il y en a déjà il y
en aurait déjà 2 millions et demi qui
serait qui seraient concernés donc voilà
moi je veux bien je l'ai dit à mes
collègues aux deux collègues qui n'ont
pas souhaité voter ce matin le texte je
leur ai dit vous pouvez penser alors
soit on est dans la politique et la
politique peut être aussi de la
communication vous me reprochez de dire
vous d'envoyer un mauvais message je dis
j'en vois pas un mauvais message je dis
la vérité voilà dit la vérité de dire
qu'on va moins polluer
en 2025 si on garde le même schéma de
restriction c'est faux
voilà c'est faux
moi je veux un calendrier réaliste et je
veux qu'enfin les Français puissent
comprendre pourquoi on leur demande ses
efforts et leur donner le temps de
s'organiser pour le faire et de les
aider pour le faire parce que les
Français ce n'est pas que les Français
ne le veulent pas c'est que bien souvent
il ne le peuvent pas voilà
merci
merci à vous